DEPARTMENT'S REBUTTAL TO TRUMP'S
LEGAL TEAM ON THE MAR-A-LAGO
DOCUMENTS, AND WE WILL TALK
ABOUT THAT LATER BECAUSE AT THIS
SAME MOMENT, MORE THAN 150,000
PEOPLE ARE WAITING FOR WATER IN
A MAJOR AMERICAN CITY, A STATE
CAPITAL, JACKSON, MISSISSIPPI.
TONIGHT FAMILIES THERE CANNOT BE
SURE THEIR TOILETS WILL FLUSH,
THAT THERE'S ENOUGH WATER TO
BRUSH THEIR TEETH, TO SHOW, EVEN
SEND THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL.
INSTEAD, THEY SPENT THE DAY IN
LINES FOR HOURS TO GET ONE CASE
OF WATER UNTIL THE WATER RAN
OUT.
AND AFTER SPENDING THEIR DAY
LIKE THIS IN 90-DEGREE
TEMPERATURES, MANY WERE TURNED
AWAY FROM THE DISTRIBUTION EVENT
AT HAWKINS AIRFIELD.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE STATE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SAYS SEVEN
DISTRIBUTION SITES WILL BE SET
UP BY THURSDAY.
IN THE MEANTIME, PEOPLE TURNED
TO STORES WHERE THE SHELVES ARE
NEARLY BARE.
>> IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING.
IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING TO HAVE TO
FIGHT FOR SOME WATER, YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M SAYING.
YOU GOT TO MESS AROUND AND BUY
FIVE CASES OF WATER JUST TO STAY
HYDRATED.
>> Reporter: IT'S JUST KIND OF
SCARY.
WE DON'T KNOW WHEN ANYTHING'S
GOING TO GET DONE.
>> YOU COME IN THE STORE AND
IT'S EMPTY.
>> WATER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
LET'S BACK UP AND TALK ABOUT HOW
WE GOT HERE.
MODERATE FLOODING IN JACKSON,
MISSISSIPPI, CRIPPLED THE CITY'S
LARGEST WATER FACILITY.
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS TRAINED
FOR THE DEVASTATION OF
HURRICANES, THEY'VE BEEN
DEPLOYED, BUT THIS IS NOT A
DISASTER, SOME ONCE IN A
LIFETIME STORM.
AMERICAN CITIZENS IN 2022
STRUGGLING FOR THE MOST BASIC
HUMAN NEED IS THE CULMINATION OF
DECADES OF FAILURE TO FIX A
SYSTEM THAT DATES BACK TO THE
1950s.
THIS FAILURE IS SO FORESEEABLE
THAT THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED
JACKSON BY NAME MORE THAN A YEAR
AGO.
>> NEVER AGAIN CAN WE ALLOW WHAT
HAPPENED IN FLINT, MICHIGAN, AND
JACKSON, MISSISSIPPI, CAN NEVER
LET IT HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> THAT WAS PART OF THE
CELEBRATION FOR THE SENATE
PASSAGE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ACT.
IT ALLOCATED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR MISSISSIPPI INCLUDE ING
$429 MILLION FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT MONEY IS SUPPOSED TO
STRETCH ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE.
WHERE IS THAT MONEY NOW?
I'M JOINED NOW BY JACKSON CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER AARON BANKS AND
CASSANDRA WELCHLAND.
SHE'S A SOCIAL WORK ER TRYING TO
HELP HER NEIGHBORS AND A MOTHER
OF THREE TRYING TO GET HER
FAMILY THROUGH THIS CRISIS.
CASSANDRA, LET ME START WITH YOU
AND HOW YOUR FAMILY IS DEALING
WITH THIS.
>> THANK YOU, VICTOR, FOR HAVING
ME.
SO OUR FAMILY TODAY WE'VE BEEN,
YOU KNOW, WORKING TO JUST
ADJUST.
MY CHILDREN ARE OUT OF SCHOOL
AND WE HAVE BEEN HAVING TO, OF
COURSE, BUY WATER TO COOK, TO
BRUSH OUR TEETH, TO JUST DO THE
BASIC NECESSITIES THAT WE NEED
IN ORDER JUST TO KEEP OUR FAMILY
AFLOAT.
SO TODAY WAS ONLINE ZOOM AND
ALSO FEEDING OUR KIDS AT HOME,
BUT THE WATER WAS -- WE HAD LOW
WATER PRESSURE TODAY.
THE WATER WAS BROWN WHEN WE
TURNED IT ON THIS MORNING.
WE'VE GOTTEN A LITTLE BIT MORE
PRESSURE AS THE DAY HAS GONE ON,
BUT IT'S DEFINITELY BEEN OF
COURSE AN INCONVENIENCE, NOT
JUST FOR MY FAMILY BUT FOR
FAMILIES ACROSS THE CITY OF
JACKSON.
>> WE'VE GOT A PICTURE THAT YOU
SENT US OF THE WATER THAT COMES
OUT OF THE SPIGOT.
THIS IS AT YOUR BATHTUB.
THE MAYOR SAYS THAT THE CITY
RIGHT NOW IS UNDER A BOIL WATER
ADVISORY.
IF YOU BOILED THAT WATER, I
MEAN, IT'S BROWN.
WOULD YOU EVEN USE THAT WATER
AFTER BOILING IT?
>> SO WE HAVE BEEN ON A BOIL
WATER NOTICE FOR ALMOST -- A
LITTLE OVER A MONTH NOW, ABOUT A
MONTH, AND WE HAVE NOT USED THAT
WATER TO EVEN COOK WITH.
TODAY WILL BE NO OTHER DAY.
WE STILL WOULD NOT USE THAT
WATER.
WE DON'T BOIL IT TO DO ANYTHING
WITH IT BECAUSE GRIT IS IN THE
WATER, AND SO WE WILL NOT USE
IT.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN, YOU KNOW,
GOING TO THE STORE, YOU KNOW,
BUYING WATER, AND NOT JUST MY
FAMILY BUT ALSO OUR
ORGANIZATION, THE MISSISSIPPI
BLACK WOMEN'S ROUND TABLE, HOW
WE'VE BEEN SERVING THE COMMUNITY
AND HAVE BEGUN TO PUT OUR BOOTS
ON THE GROUND WITH OTHER
PARTNERS TO BE ABLE TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY.
SO NO, WE WILL NOT USE THAT
WATER, AND TODAY I HAD TO REMIND
MY KIDS, YOU KNOW, DON'T USE THE
WATER TO BRUSH YOUR TEETH.
YOU NEED TO GET A BOTTLE OF
WATER AND SO WE HAVE BOTTLES OF
WATER IN THEIR REST ROOMS
BECAUSE GRIT COMES OUT OF -- AND
OVER THE WEEKEND IT WAS EVEN
WORSE.
IT WAS BROWN, AND THIS IS EVEN
BEFORE, YOU KNOW, THE CRESTING
OF THE RESERVOIR HAPPENED.
SO IT'S A PRETTY -- IT'S A REAL
INCONVENIENCE, AND IT IS A
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE,
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT OUR CHILDREN AND YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW, ELDERS
IN THE COMMUNITY.
IT'S A REALLY BAD PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUE FOR NOT JUST MY FAMILY BUT
FOR ALL OF OUR FAMILIES IN
JACKSON, MISSISSIPPI.
>> YEAH, BEYOND CONSUMING IT OR
USING IT TO BRUSH YOUR TEETH, I
MEAN, I COULDN'T IMAGINE ANYBODY
WOULD WANT TO BATHE IN THAT
WATER THAT WE SAW IN THE
BATHTUB.
COUNCILMAN, LET ME COME TO YOU,
AND NO COMMUNITY SHOULD HAVE TO
RELY ON THE WATER WE JUST SHOWED
AND NOT HAVE, YOU KNOW,
RELIABLE, CLEAN, POTABLE WATER.
BUT I'D BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
POINT OUT THAT THIS IS A
MAJORITY BLACK CITY, 82% THERE
IN JACKSON.
TELL ME WHAT YOU'RE SEEING AND
HOW THIS IS IMPACTING THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU REPRESENT.
>> YEAH, FIRST OF ALL, I
APPRECIATE IT.
LOOK, IT IS VERY HARD TO BEAR.
THIS IS NOT OUR FIRST TIME HERE.
TWO YEARS AGO FEBRUARY WE HAD A
WINTER STORM WHERE CITY OF
JACKSON WENT AROUND FOUR WEEKS
WITHOUT WATER, BUT HOWEVER, THE
SUBJECTS AREA, WHICH IS THE WARD
I REPRESENT WENT SIX WEEKS TO
SEVEN WEEKS WITHOUT ANY WATER AT
ALL, AND SINCE THAT TIME THERE
HAS NOT BEEN A MONTH WHERE WE
HAVE NOT EXPERIENCED NO FLOW TO
LOW FLOW IN CERTAIN AREAS IN
SOUTH JACKSON.
AND SO IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE CITIZENS
HERE ARE RESILIENT BECAUSE ALL
HANDS STEP UP TO THE PLATE AS
ALWAYS TO HELP MAKE THAT WE'RE
SERVING OUR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO PROVIDE NON-POTABLE AND
POTABLE WATER, SO WE'RE USED TO
THE EMERGENCY.
SATED PART ABOUT IT IS AND THE
SAD REALITY IS THIS IS BECOMING
SOMEWHAT OF A NORM, AND WE
DESERVE A BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE
RIGHT HERE IN THE CAPITAL CITY
OF JACKSON, MISSISSIPPI.
>> SO WHAT'S THE PLAN?
I KNOW THERE WAS A WATER
DISTRIBUTION TODAY.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT, SEVERAL
HUNDRED CASES OF WATER AT THE
END OF IT CARS HAD TO JUST MAKE
A U-TURN AND LEAVE BECAUSE THERE
WAS NONE LEFT.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE FOR THE
NEXT SEVERAL DAYS OR WEEKS UNTIL
THIS IS SOLVED?
>> SO LOOK, IT WILL BE THE SAME
THAT WE DID IN 2020.
SINCE LAST NIGHT AROUND 7:30,
THERE WAS A 6,000 GALLON TANKER
DEPLOYED IN MY WARD AT FORESTER
HIGH SCHOOL THAT IS JUST
PROVIDING FLUSHING WATER.
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS THAT WE
REALIZED IS THAT PEOPLE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO FLUSH BECAUSE THAT
BECOMES A PROBLEM AS FAR AS
MAKING SURE THAT, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE HAVE THAT QUALITY OF LIFE
THEY NEED, ESPECIALLY WHEN
SCHOOL IS OUT, CHILDREN ARE AT
HOME, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE ARE AT
HOME, AND SO WE WANTED TO
PROVIDE THOSE GALLONS OF WATER
IN THOSE TANKERS THROUGHOUT WARD
SIX TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE ABLE TO
FLUSH.
ON TOP OF THAT, WE ARE TALKING
WITH PARTNERS, PEOPLE LIKE WORLD
CENTRAL KITCHEN, PEOPLE LIKE MY
COX NATIONAL BLACK CAUCUS TO TRY
TO GET HELP AND TO BRING THAT
BOTTLED WATER, THE CITY OF
JACKSON HAS STEPPED UP AND
PROVIDING POWER SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THAT, BUT YOU KNOW, AT
THE END OF THE DAY, WE NEED A
FIX, AND THE SAME ATTENTION THAT
WAS GIVEN TO FLINT, MICHIGAN, WE
NEED THAT SAME ATTENTION GIVEN
TO JACKSON.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
RESOURCES THAT NEED TO COME TO
THIS CITY, INSTEAD OF THEM GOING
TO THE STATE, WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR LEGISLATORS ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND THAT THERE'S
SOME TYPE OF EXECUTIVE AUTHORITY
TO MAKE SURE IT COMES DIRECTLY
TO THE CITY SO WE CAN DO WHAT WE
NEED TO DO EVEN IF THAT MEANS
GETTING A NEW WATER PLANT.
>> AND I'LL ADD TO, THAT VICTOR,
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT, YOU
KNOW, TOMORROW MORNING WE HAVE,
OF COURSE, PARTNERED THE
MISSISSIPPI BLACK WOMEN'S ROUND
TABLE HAVE PARTNERED WITH NEW
HORIZON CHURCH AND OTHER
PARTNERS, PEOPLE'S ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE, AND SO TOMORROW
MORNING WE WILL BE HAVING
TRUCKLOADS OF WATER THAT'S GOING
TO BE COMING EVERY DAY TO BE
ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE TO
COMMUNITIES.
AGAIN, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
AARON TALKED ABOUT IS -- AND YOU
SAID, WE ARE 80% BLACK
COMMUNITY, BUT ALSO A THIRD OF
THOSE FOLKS LIVE IN POVERTY, AND
MANY OF OUR CHILDREN ARE ON FREE
AND REDUCED LUNCH.
AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHO'S
IMPACTED THOSE FAMILIES, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT JOBS, RIGHT?
THEY HAVE TO STAY AT HOME, YOU
KNOW, WITH THEIR FAMILIES, AND
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CHILD
CARE.
SO NOT ONLY ARE WE STILL COMING
OUT OF COVID, WHICH IS AN
ECONOMIC SECURITY, YOU KNOW,
ISSUE FOR SO MANY FAMILIES,
WE'RE STILL HERE TRYING TO
PROVIDE THOSE KINDS OF
RESOURCES.
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE $1,000 SAVED
UP TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE CRISES
THAT IS BEFORE US, AND SO
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN DOING THIS
FOR TWO YEARS NOW, COMING TO OUR
OWN RESCUE, AND SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT, BUT
DEFINITELY AS AARON SAID, THE
STATE MUST KICK IN THE MONEY,
THE RESOURCES SO THAT WE CAN GET
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE FIXED.
>> THERE CERTAINLY NEEDS TO BE A
FIX.
I MEAN, EVERY HUMAN DESERVES
CLEAN WATER, AND THE PEOPL